let's talk a little bit about the
midterms I've talked about the
importance of the 2018 midterms so much
so that when people call in and ask me
do I think X Y or Z is a good 2020
candidate for the Democrats
I say I'm not ready to talk about that
let's focus on 2018 however we don't
even have to wait for 2018
there's 2017 races that we can focus on
and there's an opportunity for
get-out-the-vote to turn a major red
seat blue last week I told you Roy Moore
defeated Luther Strange in the Alabama
Republican primary one storyline last
week was Luther strange was Trump's guy
and right after strange lost Trump
distanced himself he deleted tweets
supportive of Luther strange and all of
a sudden Trump supports Roy Moore okay
another storyline last week was that Roy
Moore is a total lunatic having
previously said that the First Amendment
only applies to Christians and lots of
other wacky stuff hey man it's part of
the battle of ideas though spare me
right I've mentioned the name Doug Jones
before I've mentioned that Doug Jones is
a better option in Alabama he is the
Democratic challenger he supports
universal health care
he supports public schools he supports a
living wage and protecting Medicare and
equal pay for equal work and renewable
energy LGBTQ equality pretty solid
Democratic candidate the big news is
that Jones is trailing Roy Moore in
Alabama by fewer than six points it's
like five point seven or something like
that Alabama could be in play in the
Trump era a major opportunity to turn a
red seat blue it's fifty point two
percent to forty four point five percent
it's a poll conducted by opinion savvy
and commissioned by decision desk HQ
five percent of polled voters say
they're currently undecided you need to
be working on this campaign Google get
out the vote Doug Jones Google phone
bank for Doug Jones and you do not need
to convince any Trump lovers to vote for
Doug Jones you merely need to get people
in Alabama to vote who want to reject
the Trump agenda and want to reject this
theocratic version of Christian Sharia
that
people like Roy Moore want now I I do
want to be realistic with you right Doug
Jones is a respectable person he has
well thought-out positions Roy Moore is
a dangerous Pro Christian Sharia lunatic
who puts a religion above the law we
would imagine that in the United States
of America it would be no contest Roy
Moore with loose but this is Alabama and
part of the reason why the gap might
only be six points is that Roy Moore has
been engaged in a primary up until last
week he hasn't even really started
campaigning against Doug Jones so I
don't want to paint this as any day now
we're gonna have a Democratic senator
from Alabama but what I do want to make
very clear is that this is a special
election special elections are typically
very low turnout and this is an
opportunity before the midterms before
2020 to get involved now early December
December 12th I believe is election day
in this race get involved forget about
the polls and just try to get out the
vote because there's a real opportunity
here to turn a red seat blue in a state
that we never would have imagined it to
be possible the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad